und vor dort zu dem mann der so sehr mit
der korona krise verbunden ist wie kein
anderer karl lauterbach auch jetzt in
diesen tagen in denen wir alle das leben
ohne dieses blöde corona genießen plant
er wieder und warnt er wieder karl
lauterbach im exklusiven bild-interview
heute bei meinem kollegen mit reporter
paul ronzheimer der warnt karl
lauterbach die masken pflicht in
innenräumen ja er geht davon aus dass
die zurückkommt im herbst was für ein
mist sonst spreche ich erst mit paul
ronzheimer dem mann der dieses interview
geführt hat heute mit unserem
bundesgesundheitsminister der offenbar
während wir alle dass corona freie leben
in diesem sommer genießen voll auf wann
kurs ist und die nächsten maßnahmen im
köcher hat
jack a so sieht es aus also als ich karl
lauterbach getroffen haben nachgefragt
habe da habe ich ihm angesehen da
passiert was im herbst und ich glaube er
sagt dass jetzt um eben anders zu
klingen als andere regierungsmitglieder
in den vergangenen jahren die meist im
sommer gesagt haben ja wir hoffen dass
es jetzt vorbei ist und karl lauterbach
will derjenige sein der dann wenn es
soweit ist im herbst sagen kann ich
hab's euch ja gesagt egal ob es euch
jetzt schlechte laune macht du hast
diesen karl lauterbach heute zu diesem
exklusiv interview einem ungewöhnlichen
ort für ihn ungewöhnlichen ort getroffen
nämlich in der ukraine in lemberg also
dort wo der kanzler bisher noch nicht
war da ist ausgerechnet der
bundesgesundheitsminister warum
ja ich war auch überrascht als ich davon
gehört habe dass karl lauterbach kommt
und zwar hier wo ich stehe in lemberg
also die stadt die das muss man ja
ehrlich sagen am wenigsten vom krieg
getroffen wurde hier gab es zwar auch
immer wieder raketenalarm aber karl
lauterbach kamen auf einladung des
ukrainischen gesundheitsministers in ein
krankenhaus hat dort ja überlebende
verletzte getroffen war dann auch in
einem krankenhaus und dort in diesem
krankenhaus im keller da habe ich ihn
zum interview getroffen ja und du hast
mit karl lauterbach natürlich auch
darüber gesprochen über das verhältnis
zwischen krieg und corona also wie
schert man sich um corona in einem land
das vom krieg so stark zerstört so sehr
gebeutelt s rück da in diesen zeiten
nicht corona ganz wahnsinnig in den
hintergrund das ist die antwort von
kalla
keiner spricht über corona trotzdem
bricht das land oder das system nicht
zusammen das darf man nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen ist also
tatsächlich so dass also die eine sorge
die andere nicht also trumpfen darf wir
wollen dass die älteren menschen gut vor
kroner geschützt sind wir wollen also
dass da niemand stirbt oder stark leidet
oder longo wird bekommt ohne dass wir
das übertreiben aus muss gemacht werden
natürlich ist es so wenn ein land sich
im krieg befindet dann dominieren andere
sorgen dass es jetzt endlich gibt es
schöneres als crooner abermalig wie
gesagt ich finde ich sympathisch wenn
man es gegeneinander ausspielt nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen aber paul ich
nehme an du hast nicht allzu viele
besorgte menschen gehört in der ukraine
die sich ganz viel sorgen und carola
gemacht haben in den vergangenen drei
monaten
ja so ist es ja egal in welchem krieg
oder in welcher krise und ganz besonders
in der ukraine wo ich war in den
vergangenen jahren seitdem grund eine
rolle spielt alarm nicht gefragt moment
mal warum macht ihr euch so große sorgen
und corona in deutschland warum habt ihr
da so viel angst vor schaut doch wer bei
uns das war in afghanistan so das war
ein berg karabach so das ist hier in der
ukraine so dass natürlich dann solche
sorgen in den hintergrund geraten kai
und vor allem denkt man moment mal wo
ich denn dieser zusammenbruch des
gesundheitssystems sind ja
prognostiziert wurde natürlich auch das
gehört zur wahrheit dazu in der ukraine
da gab es jetzt auch keine bars oder
restaurants in großem umfang also von
daher social distance auf sozusagen ja
eine art unter druck nun war der
bundesgesundheitsminister und du warst
mit ihm unterwegs paul vor allen dingen
auch dort um sich ein bild zu machen
über die hygienischen zuständen in den
krankenhäusern du hast das gerade gesagt
aber auch in den städten es gibt
gigantische folgen dieses krieges eben
auch dort in den städten bei der hygiene
und es gibt eine große warnung von
carlotta macht mit blick auf die
zustände in den städten schauen sie ein
cholera ausbruch wäre tatsächlich sehr
bedenkt wer sehr katastrophal
ich kann die tatsächliche gefahr jetzt
nicht einschätzen aber es ist
tatsächlich so die hygiene bedingungen
in diesen städten sind eine katastrophe
und wäre selbst cola wäre denkbar wir
schreiben uns dass paul mit deinen augen
also was siehst du von diesen schlimmen
zuständen in den städten
was cholera angeht da geht es vor allem
um mario pohl also die stadt die
natürlich in den schlagzeilen ist und
war die russland erobert wo fast jedes
haus zerstört ist die wasserversorgung
kaputt ist wo katastrophale hygienische
zustände herrschen aber auch in anderen
städten im osten der ukraine wo so
erbittert gekämpft wird wo es die gefahr
und die sorge gibt dass die ukrainische
armee weil keine munition mehr hat und
da sagt karl lauterbach in diesen
städten da könnte eines einem
cholera-ausbruch geben nicht nur er sagt
dass auch das britische
verteidigungsministerium hat dafür heute
gewarnt dass also nehmen wir mit von
deinem interview heute mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister in der ukraine
in lemberg die warnung vor allem
cholera-ausbruch in der ukraine und
gleichzeitig die warnung ja leider auch
mit blick auf die korona lage hier in
deutschland vor wieder der rückkehr der
masken pflicht den innenräumen
spätestens im herbst danke danke für
dein interview